and the the victim Support Services
which are provided aren't really set up
to to help them with that
um and then the final thing is
um I think
I don't think there's much Point
carrying on handing out fraud
investigations in large volumes to
Uniformed offices in local forces I
think it's the wrong place for them to
do it and it's we've done surveys of
officers and they say we would rather
this was done by specialist
investigators we don't have the capacity
to do it these are really long and
complicated cases and we've got so many
other things sexual crime violent crime
anti-social Behavior to be dealing with
so I would I would give fraud
investigation to Dedicated on most of it
to Dedicated
um investigators probably you know
located at the regional or the national
level rather than just handing stuff out
to local forces who don't prioritize it
and I know why they don't prioritize
they don't prioritize it because it it
doesn't rank high enough with violent
crime sexual crime and all the other
things they're dealing with so
um you can ask them to prioritize it but
I don't think they ever really will so I
I think deal with it regionally or
nationally on the on the investigation
side and to your mind so we picked on
fraud but but
there are other examples would you see
this sitting within your fraud at the
moment ostensibly sits within city of
London Police would you see it being
sponsored by
um a particular force or sitting outside
of that as as an agency with support
from Rockies or whatever yeah I mean I
think I think a lot of the
investigations could be done at the
regional level through alongside the
Rockers provided those rockers have
significantly increased capacity and
capability to do this
um I mean there are moves in that
direction at the moment
um so
um so I think you need to expand that
Regional capacity
um and then I'm you know I'm open-minded
on the question of whether it's city of
London Police or the National Crime
agency gets involved this sort of
there's arguments on both sides to be
honest but I think I think it is really
important that we have Clarity over who
leads nationally on that
um and you know I do think there are
capabilities that the NCAA has for
example that would be useful in this
space particularly when you're dealing
with online fraud is very International
but equally the National Crime agency
isn't a victim-facing service in the way
that the police are and so I so I'm you
know so I can see both sides of that
argument thank you and then then on the
you you touched on this in your opening
marks but the the 43 force model that we
have
at the moment
um I think you're absolutely right to
say there needs to be that connection
between the local force and the local
community and people need to see that
they've got that responsive police force
in their area
but what does a better model look like
to you well I mean in our review we said
we argued actually you didn't need to
merge the 43 forces we thought because
one I mean when you when you get into
this debate everyone says 43 is not the
right number and I think the right I
think the wrong place to start is with a
number I think we I think you need to
start with you know form follows
function you know what should have been
locally what should have been regionally
what should have been nationally locally
I think it should be local crime
investigation dealing with antisocial
Behavior neighborhood policing
safeguarding
um response 24 7 response and then at
the regional level I would put a lot
more of the specialism at that level
um
uh which would be specialist
capabilities Firearms things like that
um Operational Support functions horses
you know those kind of things
um and uh and also you could move some
of the um the business support functions
to that level as well you know I don't
think you need 43 different HR
departments I mean some forces are doing
this already so they're already
recognizing that by collaborating on
some of these back office functions
if you look what they did in Scotland
and again I don't think you need to I'm
not arguing you need a National Force I
don't I don't I think England's too big
um for that Wales you could have a
National Force probably in terms of
population size that I think that would
be
um
workable
um I'm not saying it's the right thing
to do but it would be in terms of the
size I think it would work
um England I think is too big for a
National Force but if you look at what
they've done in Scotland
they did they have improved the quality
of their specialist capabilities by
having you know having them done once
rather than eight times and they saved a
lot of money
um now England and Wales also saved a
lot of money because we've been through
an austerity program and people have
sold police stations and rationalized a
lot of back office functions and so on
um but hmic FRS has repeatedly found
that more money could be saved through
increased collaboration
and
um Scotland saved twice as much as they
thought they would at the beginning of
the merger so that to me says there is
money to be saved and I'm not saying
that just to save money I'm saying that
is money that could be invested in
Frontline policing you know it doesn't
need to be invested in back office
functions
um so
um so I think uh yeah I I think doing
more with the regions uh would be really
would be a big step forward
and then sorry last last question for me
um you you spoke in your opening marks
around
um the importance of moving to a
preventative model and also
prioritization
um
when I talked to my local police force
they spend especially the neighborhood
for say the neighborhood policing team
they spend an inordinate amount of their
time dealing with mental health issues
with parking issues you know things that
really aren't in their domain at all but
no one else is there to deal with them
so they end up in the police's lap
um now if you if you're shifting to a
model where you're going to prioritize
crime and what the police are you know
is on their job description and they
should be doing
um and if you're prioritizing in that
way
then there's an obvious problem that
these issues aren't going to be picked
up by the police anymore so I'm just I'm
curious to know what your thinking is
around that and and what resourcing is
needed elsewhere whether in the
authorities or traffic authorities to to
start to deal with some of these things
that are currently on the police is
playing yeah I I think I think it is
right that the police have quite a
general response function so in relation
to 24 7 response I think it's right they
have that because you need somebody to
have responsibility for all the other
stuff that no one will deal with and to
be honest they're people who probably
need the powers of police officers
because often those will be situations
where there'll be conflict and there
might be criminality
um there's often just you know a danger
of harm and risk and so the presence of
an officer with those powers can help to
de-escalate that so I think it's
important that the police have that
General response function
um but we have to be really clear what
what is it that we are um are we
deploying police officers to things
which their skills and Powers
um are going to be the most effective
way of dealing with the risk
um I'll give you an example of something
which I don't think would fit that so
police officer I mean if you talk to
anyone who works on response they'll say
they spend an inordinate amount of time
in hospital essentially guarding people
with mental health problems waiting to
be assessed by the NHS I don't think
anyone thinks that's a useful that's a
good use of police officers time
you know it should be within the remit
of the National Health Service I would
have thought to be able to make sure
that where there are people waiting to
be assessed that um that they're
properly looked after and that you know
there's proper Security in place I don't
think you should just take you know
often two police officers off a shift to
to sit there for hours and hours and
hours waiting for someone to be assessed
in hospital that seems to be that is not
that is not a that is not a job that it
is necessary for a police officer to do
um but they end up doing it because no
one else will do it so I think that
means working with the NHS to deal with
that and I think another example would
be things where
um on the sort of
what is the role of the police in
prevention
the police have always had a
preventative role in fact if you go back
to peel in the 19th century that was the
principal role as to prevent crime
rather than actually having to
investigate crime it was about
um
having a deterrent effect through a
police presence on the street and
um but what is the police route I think
that I think the Police role in
prevention is really important but it
should be about the police having a
preventative mindset so when they're
responding to things they're thinking
how can we stop this happening again who
do I need to refer this to whether it's
Social Work youth work or whatever to to
deal with the fundamental problem but
it's not about the police delivering the
preventative work
um and so for example I heard the other
day about a a program where
um they were looking at troubled
families
um I'm not sure if it's part of the
trouble families program nationally but
it was a thing looking at families have
got lots of multiple problems
and they had pcsos going in there to
work with the families to try to address
some of their problems including you
know getting to know the kids and you
know they were talking about kids
playing computer games pcsos playing
computer games with the kids and I can
sort of understand why they ended up
doing it because they're thinking this
family causes so many call outs how can
we stop that from happening but to me
that should be a job for youth workers
or for social workers rather than for
police Community Support officers or
police officers so it's about policing
have a preventative mindset but then
working with others to deliver the
prevention and I think sometimes the
problem is the police get dragged into
doing the prevention because they think
no one else is going to do it so it is
it is I mean it does come down to
resources and working relationships with
the NHS local authorities and others to
make sure that uh you know if there's a
problem like that they're able to deal
with it and then the police can focus on
doing the things that that we want the
police to deal with
I'm going to bring in Lee Anderson at
this point
yeah yeah just a couple of questions for
me I think public perception of our
police force is is really important and
sometimes the perception uh of my
constituents in Astrid is not to the
local police force it's true what they
see on TV and what they see see down
here especially with the protesters
we're seeing on a regular basis and they
seem to think uh well they know there's
there's probably in a lot of occasions
there's a lack of action or appears to
be a lack of action to move some of the
protesters we've seen especially on my
tour how do we change that perception
are we doing enough for you
well I think that um I think you're
right about perception I think it's
sometimes unfair on local policing that
they tend to see things that are
happening in other forces and it feeds
back or even indeed in other countries
um that often has an impact because I
think people tend to see policing as as
one thing
um and it it impacts things can happen
all over you know all over the world and
in different parts of this country that
can affect people's perceptions of
policing
um I think that's just part of the
territory but um I mean on protest I
think that um it's it's a it's a really
it's a difficult it's a difficult
balance to strike um and policing is all
about balance you know it's all about
um particularly when you're doing
enforcement action and it's about how
um you know they'll get criticized for
being too heavy-handed and they'll get
criticized for not being heavy-handed
enough so I don't envy police officers
having to make those decisions
um and um uh but I think it's clear that
um they are uh that their role is to
facilitate to facilitate
Democratic lawful peaceful protest
um uh but obviously it's to make sure
that traffic can also float freely and
so on and so they have to be able to
deal with obstructions and use the law
um in that way but we also have to trust
the police to make the to use their
discretion because these are operational
matters and uh and so
um so I'm I wouldn't want to
second-guess the people on the ground in
some of these situations
okay
um I guess
the skill set needed and the stuff
required for for police forces up and
down the country are different in
different areas for example in in I know
in Rochdale and Rotherham we've had
problems of grooming gangs um in
Lincolnshire it's more rural crime and
again in in London and the city's
different crime all together is this
other skills uh it's a training
different for a police officer in each
area and if not should it be
um it does vary
um it does vary and um and obviously you
know policing a rural area is quite
different to policing you know London or
greater Manchester or whatever
um so I think that it it does it does
rightly vary but what I do think we need
to be clear about is that the
Professional Standards should be the
same across the whole country
um and I think
um we argued in our report that the
College of policing should have more
powers to make some of those
Professional Standards mandatory because
currently
um there's authorized professional
practice which Chief constables should
follow but they're not um legally
obliged to follow
um and that can lead to variation I
think in there are areas I think where
there areas of policing where the risk
is High where the evidence base is
really clear about what works and where
the public where these are things that
are key to public confidence I think the
standard of training should be the same
across the country so for example stop
and search probably most controversial
police tactic
um
you know there's still huge variation in
training around stop and search in in
the implementation of that training
um and we can't we kind of know what
works well in terms of doing stop and
search effectively and in ways that
command confidence but it's still not
being done consistently enough so I
would I would make some of the training
standards around that mandatory across
the whole country one question please
Joe it's a quick one my local police
tell me that morale police officers is
affected by a weak sentencing in court
so you can have prolific criminals get
them off the street and then a week
later they're back on the street how
does that affect them around do you
think courts are doing enough to help
please
I think morale is affected by
um failings in the rest of the Criminal
Justice System absolutely yeah
um and
um sometimes that might be about
sentencing but sometimes it's just about
um the fact that there are such long
waits to get things through the criminal
justice system
um the fact that victims drop out and
don't want to continue with
investigation because it's just taking
too long
um and and we know post covered because
the courts are closed there's there's
backlogs and so on so I think
um I was supportive actually of the idea
of a royal commission we talked about
raw commissions we're all commissioned
into the criminal justice system because
I think actually
um the criminal justice system the rest
of the Criminal Just policing has its
problems well I think the problems are
much worse actually in the courts in
probation in uh in the prison system and
I think we should have a royal
commission into into that
it's very interesting okay uh Carolyn
Harris thank you thank you document
thank you Chad
um you've touched on the different kinds
of crime crime today is completely
different to what it was when I was a
Youngster and to give a good example
just over the last five weeks I've had
police in my house
um
on three knocking at Wellness was it
maybe connected to the fact I'm a member
of parliament but my bank account got
scammed three times in three weeks
um I have had malicious emails sent
somewhere else regarding trying to harm
me and I've done some DV training three
different completely different subjects
same police officers on all three things
how can we expect those police officers
to have in-depth knowledge they could
never solve my bank
sure they couldn't solve it but they
have to be involved what are the skills
are we going to need going forward for
police to actually be able to deal with
all these issues they'd expect it to
yeah um no well I agree with
um with what you're saying I think that
um as policing becomes more complex the
idea that this idea of omni competence
that took hold during the austerity
period which was that police officers
should just be able to you know
multitask essentially and just do lots
of different things and of course it's
always true that a constable
um is always going to be multitasking
someone on response they're going to be
dealing with all sorts of stuff but I do
think that um because crime is becoming
more complex you do need more
specialization in the police Workforce
so to deal with things like fraud cyber
crime
um domestic violence I mean there is
specialization in in these areas but I
think it needs to go a lot further so
um so yeah I think we should we should
move away from this idea that
um that you can just train one person
once to deal with all of these different
things that actually
um we need to we need to have
specialization a way it should be like
the NHS you know you go to the GP for
the
to have a general look but then if
there's a if there's a serious problem
it gets passed on to a specialist and we
I think we do need more specialism in in
policing
thank you very much
um
I really worry about the the raft of
extra duties that the police are
currently expected to undertake when I
think about how much youth work they're
doing how much Social Work they're doing
every conversation I have with the
police around a specific Hot Topic is
not really their job to be worrying
about and there is a perception of
people when they complain that um
they've emailed me and they'll say I
reported x and x and the police haven't
gone back to me whereas years ago
there's a very nostalgic view that the
police should be telling the complainant
everything and we know that that's not
possible and rightly so but
how can the commune how can the police I
know I've got to give a shout out for
South Wales police Swansea you've been
absolutely fantastic really are
brilliant in trying to get involved and
to be preventative but how can we have
police officers who are more more
representative of the areas that they
they are working in
yeah I mean well it's really important
that the police are connected to the
community yeah absolutely and um and
that is the the foundation of our model
of policing and
um and that means
um that means trying to recruit recruit
people locally I mean that is a problem
in London where um housing costs are
high and you know a large bulk of the
offices are coming you know commuting in
from outside London
um which then affects the diversity
um so it is important that the police
reflect the community
um uh you know peel said that the police
are the public and the public are the
police
um so the you know so the the police do
need to reflect the community it's
important that we make sure the police
Workforce reflects the diversity of the
communities that we have that has
improved a bit not enough particularly
in terms of black recruits hasn't really
improved a great deal much better in
terms of Asian recruits into policing
but
um so that's important and it's really
important to do good community policing
so we say in our report that
neighborhood policing during the
austerity period neighborhood policing I
think got seen as a bit of a nice to
have
um because and you understand why
because when you're looking at when
you're dealing with life and limb you
think the most important thing is to get
there and to respond and then to
investigate crimes that you detect that
you pick up but
um neighborhood policing is really
fundamental and if you look at the what
happens to public confidence in the
police over time it goes up when you
invest in neighborhood policing and it
falls when you stop investing in
neighborhood policing and that's what
we've seen over the last over the last
20 years
so I think it is and actually there's a
good evidence base for neighborhood
policing there's really good evidence
that
um neighborhood teams doing problem
solving activity in local communities is
effective at reducing crime
um and if we're worried about resources
the other thing we need to do is is
follow the evidence space
um and I know and the College of
policing does a lot of work on this I
think it is really important to the
officers are aware of what works
um a neighborhood policing is one of the
things that that works both in terms of
reducing crime and in terms of improving
public confidence which is basically
those are the two big things we want to
we want to see
thank you
um the police foundation's review
suggests a new politically a mission for
policing is needed
I think and this is personal I think
that this
um
demand for a degree to go into policing
we are losing a huge amount of talented
people who are brilliant at the Hands-On
stuff but are not not academic and we
all know that being academic doesn't
necessarily mean that you have the
common sense to deal with the local
police and the stuff that really can get
into the nitty-gritty of a community do
you think that we need a new mission for
please send them why
um well I mean I think I mean there are
two things there one's about the entry
routes um where I mean I'm supportive of
the of the new entry routes because I
think that the jobs become more complex
and I think that um and I think that the
training needs to be needs to be to a
higher level
um but you shouldn't and this isn't the
case you shouldn't you should never need
a degree to join right and that's the
and you don't you don't that's the key
thing you you get one on the job
um and I think that's the right balance
so if you don't have a degree
um you can join and you'll get one
you'll get one on the job the most
important the important thing on
recruitment is we need multiple ways of
joining because the old days where
everyone just joined as a PC
um that doesn't that doesn't reflect the
complexity of the police work which
which we're now seeing and we're seeing
a lot of forces now do direct entry
detectives for example so you can join I
know a lot of people who mid-career are
now joining the police in detective
roles now they're probably the sort of
people who don't want to roll around
dealing with Pub fights on a Friday
Saturday nights to be honest with you um
but they'd quite like to be a detective
and that's fine right isn't that fine we
need we need people who are going to be
able to get out there and do some of the
rough stuff
um but we also need people who are going
to investigate fraud and cyber crime and
so on so I I think you need you need
multiple routes in
um and then on the mission I think the
mission needs to be I think what we need
is clarity about the mission so that it
crime is is core but it's not the only
thing as I said before I think it's
about
um maintaining order and upholding the
law
and there's a whole range of things that
flow out of that and then being really
clear about what the functions are that
the police perform and in our report we
set out I think five core functions
um but the key thing is
in when looking at a particular risk is
the deployment of a police officer to
deal with that
um the necessary and is it is it the
right thing to is it are they the right
person to deal with it
um so is the is is a person in uniform
with
um the power of arrest the power to stop
and search people necessary to deal with
all the things that they're currently
dealing with and as I said before some
of the things I think they're currently
being pulled into it's not necessary but
that means that the rest of the system
has to come in so we need to be clear
about the role of the police and then we
need to have
um we need to be much more systemic
about thinking about the role of Health
local authorities and others in
preventing crime okay thank you I'm
going to move on to uh Gary Sandberg
thank you thank you for coming today um
in your written evidence you said that
the current pattern of stop and search
is not justified and ineffective and it
creates a significant barrier to trust
and confidence however if you look at
recent polling on stop and search it
maintains a very high support among the
general population including in every
ethnic group there is support for stop
and search so why do you think taking
away a power which has so much public
support will end up increasing the
legitimacy of policing we shouldn't take
away the power I think the power is it's
right that the police have the power
um
um although I mean they have two Powers
one is the power under Pace to stop and
search someone if they have if if they
suspect
and they're carrying a uh an illegal
item and the other power is in relation
to is the section 60 power which is
um where they don't need to have
suspicion I think on them don't need to
have suspicion stuff that's where
there's a lot of tension and I think
actually
um I think we should set a higher
threshold for the use of that power I
don't think it's not very effective in
um in detecting weapons for example and
it causes a lot of community disquiet
um having said that
um you know it is really important that
the police have the power to stop and
search people if they have suspicion
that they're doing something they
shouldn't be doing
um but the uh but it's and then it's
really important
let's look at the evidence on what
different it's really important not to
generalize across the whole country
about stop and search it's used very
intensively in London it's used much
less in some other Urban large urban
areas which also have lots of problems
with violence and and sexual crime and
so on
um it's not um it's not used as much in
the West Midlands as it's used in London
it's not used as much in Greater
Manchester as it's used in London I
think there's a specific thing in London
about the
um large-scale use of stop and search
which is causing community disquiet and
if you look at if you look at confidence
in the police in London in the last few
years it has fallen it's particularly
Fallen among among black people
um in the in the CR in the um the London
public attitude survey so there are real
issues there it's important not to
generalize from London to the whole
country
um but I think the thing the key thing
with stop and search is I would use it I
wouldn't use it on the scale that it's
being used in London
um I would what I what I do think you
you should use it proportionately and
there is really good evidence that if
you use it well and fairly and the way
in which the communication is done then
people can come away from the encounter
without feeling that they've been
humiliated or disproportionately
targeted and so on so that is really
important and if you look at the
independent office of police conduct
report on this they they looked at
stop and search interactions
and they and if you read that there's
there's a lot of those interactions
which aren't following the best practice
um so my solution to that is
follow the best practice we know what
works in terms of doing stop and search
in a way that is fair and commands
public confidence so let's let's let's
train and make sure people are following
that stand at the moment not enough of
that it's happening and it's linked to
another thing which is there isn't
sufficient emphasis in police training
we we argue on communication skills and
look thousands of police officers around
the country are really good have really
good people skills that's why they're in
policing and um and I I'm in no way
arguing uh that they're not doing that
um but if you look at the training it
doesn't get as much emphasis as you know
officer safety training for example
but actually if you want to keep offices
safe it's really important they they can
de-escalate situations that they have
those communication skills if you want
to do stop and search in a way that
commands which means that the person
who's being stopped and searched and is
completely innocent of any crime and
doesn't come away feeling that they've
been humiliated
um it's the communication is essential
and I think that's where a lot of This
falls down cool things I think on the
point you make about generic sort of it
doesn't come across in the written
evidence that that should be separated
because it it does have a generic feel
but it says the current pattern that
Stoppers searches uh not justified and I
think if you were to look at the recent
stats which say that there's been an
increase in the arrest rate on stop and
search everything from 11 to 13 that
isn't that an indication but it's
actually working the way it is
um and I don't see another power or
another way in which you can please
which does lead to 66 000 arrests within
the time period taking thousands of
weapons off the streets that does seem
to me like a perfectly Justified powered
and which is being used yeah I I is a
Justified power I think it's just about
I think it's about using it
proportionally and it's about using it
in a way which
um which follows the best practice and I
think if you do that I don't have a I
don't have a problem with it um though
it's interesting that the find rate
tends to go higher
um the less of it you do because it
tends because the less of it you do the
more of it is intelligence-led
um so
um intelligence if you look at hmrc's
work on this intelligence
intelligence-led searches
um have a much more successful and
that's where for example there's
information that's come from a third
party rather than just the officer
themselves thinking you know I'm sort of
concerned about this so I think it it's
um uh so
as I I'm not arguing against the use of
the power at all it can be effective
it's important the police have it but it
should as with all police Powers it
should be used proportionately and it's
important it's really important that
communication is done well thank you
thank you just very briefly I just
wanted to ask you about the Met
um they have National responsibilities
as well as responsibilities for policing
London do you do you think that those
should be separated out is that one of
your recommendations or not it wasn't
one of our recommendations although on
reflection I think it's a it's a good
debate to have I mean I think when we
the reason we didn't recommend shifting
some of the Mets big capabilities was we
thought that they actually deliver those
National capabilities pretty well
um I mean very well particularly in
terms of counter-terrorism where that's
um you know which is World leading and
um you know you see very little
criticism of the way the police do
counter terrorism and the Mets of the
Met delivers that capability very well
um it's the local policing they're not
very good at well I think they've
clearly got a lot of problems
um and in particular they've got a lot
they've as the Casey review made clear
they've got a lot of problems in terms
of misconduct and in terms of behavior
which I think the new Commission is now
taking on
so for me the problem in the Met is not
that they're doing counter-terrorism
um or that they're doing diplomatic
protection the problem is that I think
they lost sight of the ethics and
conduct issue and I think that now
they're starting to well the intention
is to try to grip that more right and
then that just leads me to my final
question which is about the report that
came out this morning from uh hmic FRS
um any comments on that I think it's a
it's a very robust uh well evidence
report and um and it's very damning
about the state of vetting in particular
and I think what it says to me is
um the vetting units need more capacity
to deal with the flow of people that are
now coming through
um I would have preferred we'd recruited
a bit more gradually rather than rushing
to recruit to hit a Target because I
think the problem is when you do that
you hear in the report that people feel
Under Pressure to let people through
when
um because the force is worried about
not meeting its numbers so I think we we
need to think about quality not just
bums on seats and
um the so improved and the College of
policing and the other and some of the
other National regulations are really
good on this I think the national
regulations and the national best
practice is there but it's not being
implemented by the forces effectively so
I think that's that's an example when I
said that the college for should have
some mandatory Powers over Professional
Standards investing would be another one
where
um actually everybody should just be
um reaching those National standards
rather than being they're being such
inconsistency in decision making in
training
um in resourcing and so on well lucky
for us we've got the the National
College with us this morning so we will
be able to put those questions uh to uh
the college but thank you very much for
your evidence this morning that's been
very helpful in setting the scene for us
as we start the inquiry and the
questions that we should be asking in
the coming session so thank you for your
time thank you very much
running a little bit over aren't we I've
got to finish by quarter two to him
yes
well uh thank you very much for
attending our session this morning and
I'm just going to get you to introduce
yourselves to the panel if we could
start with you Martin that would be very
helpful good morning everyone my name is
Martin Hewitt and I am chair of the
National Police Chiefs Council
good morning everyone my name is fester
sakim busoy and I'm the police and crime
commissioner for bedfordshire and the
lead for prevention for the institution
of police and crime commissioners
good morning my name is Andy Marsh and
I'm chief executive Chief Constable of
the College of policing thank you
um I would just like to to start us off
uh where I I
um asked the last question actually in
the first panel
at the very disturbing report that came
out this morning from hmic FRS I just
having looked at that I just wondered
what what is the problem what's the
problem that the police have with women
that's the thing that just occurs to me
what what is the problem there perhaps
Martin would you like to start
um so I've uh spent the first couple of
hours this morning responding in the
media to um to that report which is a
very very difficult report for the
service to receive and as I said there I
think a number of the particular
examples will be quite shocking to um to
members of the public
now there's a lot of work that has been
um going on in relation to this as as
has already been alluded to we've had
issues and there have always been issues
and we've we've done Lots around around
culture but I think the once it was it
became known that the the kidnapper and
murderer of Sarah everard was a serving
police officer I think that shocked the
organizations into a into a different
place really and and having to address
the issues some of the issues in
relation to the culture that we have and
still have in Parts in the service and
then what we need to do about them so
there has been an enormous lot of work
that has been taking place during the
period while this review has been
undertaken by HMI cfrs the work that
that you will be aware of through our
national coordinator to deal with all
the aspects around violence against
women and girls but importantly and I
chair the group at the center that
oversees this not just looking at what
we do how we deal with reports that come
from externally but very importantly and
I think getting to the Crux of your
question how we deal internally with the
issues that we have to face and we are
still facing those issues every Chief
Constable over the last year 18 months
has gone back through into their
organizations and done a number of
things one of those things is has just
been alluded to by Rick is is really
looking at how well each organization is
is
um adhering to the the code of practice
in relation to vetting and the practices
and that work goes on
the another is creating a culture in the
organizations where it is very very
clear from the top that it is
unacceptable the kind of behaviors that
we've seen and and some of the kind of
behaviors and the the the sexism and the
misogynistic behaviors that you refer to
uh is it endemic in the culture of the
police there's misogyny I think misogyny
is endemic in society
and the police and the police are
representative of society but what I
would say is it's more important that we
root that out in our organization
because of the role that we have as a
service and the powers that we have it's
even more important than it is in any
other organization where I think all of
these issues do exist we've so really
getting a culture of calling out
Behavior like that and then the really
important point is we've gone back every
Force has gone through all of the the
issues that are being dealt with through
their misconduct processes they've been
accelerating their processes and what
that has meant is and we've all seen it
story after Story of officers where it
emerges their behavior they're being
sacked from the organization and whilst
that is really challenging to our
reputation and trust and confidence in
the service from my perspective it's
really important that we carry on doing
that and I you know we will see more
stories that are negative stories
because the organizations are dealing
with those issues we've got to deal with
those where it exists we've already
spoken this morning or in your first
panel about how things have changed and
particularly the impact of technology
and social media and and many of the
many of the awful stories that have
emerged have been where officers are
sharing information and having
conversations in a social media context
and we've got to deal with those but I
guess really all I can say is that this
is absolutely at the top of agendas for
all of the chief constables we are
dealing with the issues both externally
and internally that get to the core of
your question and we will carry on doing
that we will work and implement the
recommendations that have come out of
today's risk report you know 43
recommendations in a number of areas and
Mr surprise then I mean I was just
looking very briefly about some of the
things that were in the report around
senior officers pursuing women officers
for sex viewing pornography at work
insulting comments about women and their
appearance and this issue of the booty
patrols where police officers were
stopping pretty women
you weren't shocked by that then you
kind of knew this was all going on I
find that I find them I didn't know that
that was all going on obviously but I
find those shocking and and disgusting
quite frankly that that behavior look as
we've already has already been said
people re need the police to keep them
safe and make them feel safe people call
the police and the population actually
isn't it for women and precisely people
call the police at times when they're
under that they've got issues they're
they're at the worst they're scared
they're frightened and they've got to be
able to trust that the police officers
that are turning up there are turning up
there to do the job that they're there
to do and to do it properly and this in
various examples and you've given some
there and there are more in that report
which is an awful report from the
perspective of the service those
examples there but we have to deal with
those and we are dealing with those but
we've got to work through and and
continue to do that and sadly what I
think that will mean is there will be
more stories on of so you know officer X
being sacked for this behavior and that
but I'm comfortable with that because
we've got to be open and demonstrate
that we're not prepared to accept this
kind of behavior in our organizations
okay I don't know if any other member of
the panel wants to say something yes
thank you chair
um so recognizing the problem that is
shocking and is unacceptable I've been
in the place since 1987
um in Chief Council of two police forces
before this actually when I joined the
police at only 10 of our Workforce was
female actually we're now about 34 a
question came up which we'll probably
return to
um uh on new entry roads the new entry
routes attracting a much more diverse
range of candidates there used to be
only one way into policing now there's
three with multiple facets feeding off
them but we talked about Rick talked
about degree holders apprenticeship
detective as an entry route that's
attracting 14 of black and ethnic
minority candidate and sixty percent of
the entrance on that route are women so
policing is changing first thing I'd say
and thank goodness for that we need to
address this problem and root it out
what's the College of policing doing
about it um we are responsible for
training knowledge skills and best
practice so one of the areas of best
practice that we've shared is um some
training which is about the abuse of
police powers for a sexual purpose and
that is the most accessed it shows how
seriously police forces are taking it
the most access of our learning packages
in the last 12 months abuse of Authority
for sexual purpose now I feel so
strongly about this
this problem of misogyny and sexism that
actually in my first week at the college
I asked for the guidance on outcome
sanction for gross misconduct to be
Rewritten to take into account how
seriously this is impacting on public
confidence if we don't address it
properly so that those deciding what
happens when gross misconduct is found
and that's either Chief constables or
legally qualified chairs will take into
account the impact on public confidence
and use the most appropriate most
serious sanction available to make sure
that those behaving those in such a
disgraceful way exit the service okay
and and we will come on to this I think
in in some of the later questions but
you were talking about recruitments and
clearly we will be just discussing
recruitment but you know the vetting
again I was just looking at the list of
people who've got got into the police
um who've got
um well
I assume uh racially aggravated
um violence someone who'd exposed
himself seven times over a two-week
period someone who was known to be a
pimp I mean so there's clearly a big
problem as this report highlights with
the vetting process I mean you're saying
it's good that we're getting more people
through but clearly we want the vetting
process to work effectively don't we and
that's not at the moment yeah of course
yeah because the college rights has a
number of levers it can pull to ensure
consistency over good practice and
standards one of those levers is the
authorized professional practice on
vetting which was last reviewed and
Rewritten in April 2021 so quite
recently
actually there is as the report and it's
a Well evidence report identifies in
some cases a lack of compliance with
that good practice in other areas such
as checking social media accounts the
vetting needs to be the vetting
authorized professional practice needs
to be reviewed and Rewritten and I
guarantee that I will do I will do that
within the time scale and stick later if
you don't mind share a thing the fastest
route yeah and then I'm going to get
together I mean I I anyone who read this
report will be absolutely astounded by
someone able to say examples that were
given and I can assure you that many of
my colleagues we've been talking about
this this morning and many are asking
very very scrutinous questions of the
chief constables because police and
crime Commissioners are elected to
scrutinize and oversee the work of the
police force especially that of their
Chief constables but one thing that I
feel very strongly about is that
policing really needs to drop the
defensiveness
when this kind of challenge comes out uh
and I I have to be honest in saying that
you know um Martin and Andy they've been
very very open I haven't sensed that
kind of defensiveness but I think within
some elements within policing there is
this defensiveness and my Approach has
always been look as somebody who was I
mean I'm no police officer I I used to
be a special Constable uh who was seen
firsthand the amount of powers
that police officers have which puts
them in a very very unique position
compared to the average members of the
public even you
um Madam chair uh it with that level of
power must come
um an accepted level of scrutiny uh and
uh more of our police officers and
police staff must be willing to accept
that quite rightly uh the public expect
um questions to be answered and
standards to be set much higher so um in
many political crime commissions as far
as I'm aware they're investing more
money into a Professional Standards
departments that's what we're doing in
our collaborative partnership in
bedfordshire chemistry in Hertfordshire
and I for I actually chose to go and see
for myself how this extra investment is
being deployed by the chief officers and
some of the changes that they're making
and the outcome that they're having as
well but I I've got to say to you it is
a very very concerning uh report
thoughts and many of my colleagues will
be asking their Chief constables I have
done this morning uh how well he knows
what is going within his business right
chair and on the element to this
morning's report there was a piece in
there about how
um in one force half of the misconduct
proceedings were against police officers
who had served less than two years in
post and so do you think from because
you mentioned just now about the changes
to the vetting process which had come in
earlier last year do you think that
those changes are working do you think
they're filtered down enough or do you
think they're the wrong changes because
the evidence suggests in this report but
for new recruits there doesn't seem to
be working at the moment
yeah can I just clarify
um it's a question about initial
training or vetting it's about the whole
assaulted the whole recruitment process
of the original one but because you
mentioned okay you know the decided to
go on that bit so um policing certainly
in my service is recruiting at an
unprecedented unprecedented level a a
much needed and very welcome uplift of
20 000 officers over a three to four
year period what that means in reality
is 50 000 new people uh entering placing
during that time period and that is a
huge opportunity to change the cultural
policing for the better and and improve
it the the attrition rate
um for um student officers that drop out
or leave the service or other means
um tends to be about seven percent
um which actually is too many but when
you compare it to other sectors that's
not as high as you might read and
reported in some aspects of the media is
the vetting working
um to make sure we're getting the right
people in I think the answer absolutely
and for two reasons one is the process
as it exists now is not being applied
with sufficient and consistent in rigor
the second reason there are improvements
in the vetting process that we need to
make in the authorized professional
practice there is clearly that is not
doing its job and to the extent that we
would expect it however there are many
tens of thousands of absolutely
fantastic vocational public spirited
people coming in to politic in terms of
the the initial training I think we've
heard a lot of evidence today that the
job is incredibly complicated if if we
are to avoid putting in layers of
managerial process and Rule setting
checking and rechecking we we need a
critical thinking well-informed
professionals that understand what good
looks like when they're initially
attending when they're investigating and
so that they can deliver the sort of
service that the public expects now as
the chief executive the College of
policing it's my job to do the very best
within affordable boundaries and so that
policing can do just that with the
widest pool of new recruits from across
the whole of society I'm really happy
chair to answer any other questions
specifically about training when you
when you need
okay
um
Carolyn
thank you thank you chair um
what will the police force of the future
need to win to do to increase trusting
in the police one of the conversations I
regularly have with my local police
officers is how there is no trust from
the community and the police it very
often that is due to National issues not
local issues but they pray the price
locally for that what what need what do
we need to do to improve that trust
so um so let me tell you I mean
first point is
um
all of these issues that we've just
spoken around over the last over the
last couple of years have really dented
I think people's sense of trust and
confidence in policing try you know the
confidence that you can trust the police
to do what they need to do so we have to
keep working very very hard
um in relation to to dealing with those
issues and rooting out the people that
shouldn't be there in the service
the conversations that have already
happened uh in the previous panel around
around neighborhood policing local
policing whatever we want to call it I
think is is absolutely critical to the
service however far forward we go in and
what I would describe it as is that
connectedness with the local community
people want to feel that the police are
there and the police understand the
problems that they have and they're
doing what they can do to assist with
those problems so I think that's a
really important Point maintaining that
degree of connectedness through however
we configure you know neighborhood
policing local policing whatever we call
it and I think it's really important
Point as well that that is very local
and I think you know there will be
impressions of the police that come from
media come from National stories but I
think a lot of this is about how me and
those around me feel we are connected
with our local police service so we need
to make sure that that is happening I do
think we have to address people's
understanding of the role of the police
which is where we've got to you know the
very early session and I think chair you
made the point about it was only 24
because I think most people think the
police are there for Crime which we
obviously are and we need to be doing
that but the vast majority and certainly
the majority of calls for service that
all forces across the UK are dealing
with are not to deal directly with crime
and we are finding ourselves in other
spaces being these the emergency service
that will that will respond and I think
some of that we need to be able to have
a narrative with the public that
explains that situation
your own example when you talked about
the crimes that have been impacted on
you from in a digital way I think takes
us into a into another place about how
we better get into that and I think it
links into the prevention point because
the reality is when your bank account
was impacted you would have been one of
thousands of victims that may well be
all over the place and the offender may
not even be in these islands so the
ability for South Wales police to
investigate that crime is fairly limited
but what we can what we have to be
involved in is Is How We Do prevention
and how we work with agencies and
organizations at Regional levels at
National level and increasingly at
International level to be dealing with
that criminality and I think some of
this is about
thinking of the role of policing in a
different the role of the police in a
different way if someone came and
damaged your house it's a
straightforward investigation in the way
that we would understand when someone's
impacted on your bank account remotely
it's a very different role that the
police is playing in that role and I
think we need to collectively look at
what our expectation is of what we
should be doing and what we can be doing
we always have a victim care I think
responsibility as you two to members of
the public but it's really defining
maintaining that connection that
connectedness at a local level and then
I think taking that step back to look at
what our role can be because when it
comes to those kind of issues what
really we need to be having a collective
prevention aspect because the big the
big player in that example is your bank
and the systems that your banking runs
on and the systems that other people are
using to access into there so we
collectively and by we I don't just mean
policing I mean we and including with
with Parliament need to be impacting in
a preventive sense with those
organizations to make sure that they are
doing everything that they can do to
make sure that it is very difficult to
penetrate your your online banking and
and commit a crime so I think it's
looking at it in a from a slightly
different perspective someone punching
somebody outside the pub is still the
territory we have always been in
what happened to you and there's lots of
other examples that we could give we
need to re-define our role and work with
all the other people that we need to
work with and include in having the the
legislative framework and then the the
weight that that the park government can
give to ensure that everyone that needs
to be playing their preventive role is
playing it
in total agreement I agree with what
what um Martin just uh mentioned there
um but another thing that I actually
wanted to um highlight is that I found
in my or less commissioner that you know
to all intents and purposes police
officers are absolutely good at their
jobs
you know and I do not want to leave
anyone with the impression that there
are any police officers what that I have
come across anywhere anyway yet
um who are sat down at a police station
waiting for a job to do
there just isn't one I know that I'm
aware of anyway
um but one thing I think that policing
really needs to start getting better at
doing in the 21st century is explaining
to the public
what it does
how he does it and why does it
because a lot of the uh perception of
policing nowadays as far as I see is
driven by social media an incident
happens there is a video clip that's
about 10 seconds long and that gives you
a snapshot of what has actually happened
and maybe that's all there is to it but
often if I use the example of
um say a vehicle stop now until I became
a special Constable I just thought the
powers that the police used to um stop
someone in a vehicle was exactly the
same as stopping search now I haven't
been stopped in search six times myself
um I did not realize actually the powers
were different so if I was to see a
vehicle stop online as one of your
colleagues um was uh some years ago and
it was on social media and or the police
did not follow due process did not do
they go wisely properly and everybody
piles in all of a sudden they spreads
but I'm saying to myself why was no one
explaining to the public that the powers
of the police use to do a is different
to the power that we use to do B
and there's a process that they have to
go through and so I think there's maybe
that's some of that you know the college
will want to take on um and deal because
that that process of explaining to the
public what the police are doing how
they do it and why they do it that
explanation to the public is so so
crucial I think it would help to um
re-address some of the misperceptions
that also lead to uh this Bri this trust
issues the one thing the other thing I
want to just mention very briefly around
community policing fundamentally it was
the public one from the police
I wanted to be there when I need you
dealing with the issues that I've got
and hopefully the criminals get locked
up
now obviously when the issues with the
criminal justice system
the police get the blame for that
because as far as the public are concern
the police are the start and end of the
entire Criminal Justice System again I
think there needs to be a better level
of explanation to the public about how
the whole criminal justice system works
and that's why some police and crime
commission they actually invest in a lot
more in victim engagement officers so
that actually work with victims of crime
when an incident occurs so they know
that there's a time when they pass over
from the police
to the courts and then the judges so I
think this is something that really
needs to be done but lost everyone
coming to policing uh I in my Force for
example we now invest about I think
about 10 to 11 percent of our entire
uniform police Workforce are dedicated
to community policing and as Rick
mentioned earlier on during the
austerity period
um community policing was pretty much
disbanded in many forces and if they
were there they were mostly on paper but
they were mostly doing response related
work not the early intervention
prevention diversion um work now with
the other number of offices coming in
and it's um Andy mentioned there's a
great opportunity to reinvest again in
community policing but I must say to you
that the fact that too many offices are
stuck in a e
H too many officers are dealing dealing
with mental health jobs our communities
are not feeling the full benefits of
this uplifting officers in my view I can
just say very lastly that in
bedfordshire I have I asked the force
to provide me with some data of what I
call non-police police jobs that our
officers are doing
uh in one of the smallest police forces
in the country in terms of um funding
bedfordshire police officers response to
Malone spent 53 000 hours
on Mental Health jobs alone and spent on
average 174 minutes in a e waiting for a
Handover in the hospital that was the
equivalent of 28 full-time police
officers that's an entire response team
doing nothing for just dealing with
mental health jobs alone
and many of this would be new recruits
and they can't be on the streets
patrolling whilst they're sat in a e or
looking for a missing person
done something that needs to change
just mentioned three things I think are
important in answering the question
around trust and confidence so the the
first thing is
um the police need to be there for
people when they need them that means
that when they telephone them and when
they expect to attend because something
very serious has happened now that that
was why the College of policing was very
pleased to share the evidence base on
why it's valuable to attend burglary
dwelling of people's houses and to
restore the public and solve crime and
reduce it
um on each of these three things there's
a payback
um if we are to get the basics right we
need the time to do it we need to
address the non-police demand that
festered us has articulated the second
thing that will rebuild trust is
performance we need to be effective at
cutting crime catching criminals and
keeping people safe and the college
working in partnership with the mpcc
intends to declutter the environments
that officers have got the skill to
acknowledge the time to do just that
second Payback
they cannot do that if the criminal
justice system is not working more
effectively up to three years to get a
rate trial um to a court is simply
unacceptable for everyone
um so the criminal justice system needs
uh serious reform and Improvement the
third the third area which will rebuild
trust and confidence is standards and
standards of expectation about what
matters most to the public whether we're
talking about burglary attendance or
rape investigation but standards of
conduct we've heard so much about that
has let us all down incredibly badly now
I I would argue if we're to sustain and
bring a 43 force model to maximum
performance maximum optimization we need
an influential and effective College of
policing I've been in this job a year
and that's what I intend to do
okay just before you coming Karen can I
just ask you when is the commitment
around attending every report of
burglary when's that going to happen
well it's happening now so it's all all
forces and many many forces already were
attending every a domestic but you know
when someone's house was burgled because
we absolutely understand the exactly now
across 43 police forces some some Chiefs
I think understandably rather put out I
know South Wales were saying that we
actually do that anyway
um my old force over the somerset that's
got fantastic grasp of its data
um told me that 93.6 of burglary dialing
was attended in person where you say
what what about the 6.4 well those are
rental houses perhaps that there's no
one in there's no one to attend and
speak to it it'll always be a small
amount of slippage I think so those are
many of forces already doing that I mean
in my first we've already been doing
that for about two three years now and I
think latest data actually show that
we've seen about 21 reduction in
burglary and when actually the evidence
is very clear when this actually happens
the success rates are very very good so
it
uh some that many of us support a
Carolyn Harris well that's southwest
police forget that right again
um
high profile cases will always make the
news more than the the good news local
stories because that doesn't sell papers
in order to uh in to get the trust back
and the confidence back in policing we
need better vetting and better
discipline processes when we do find bad
cop as it works what's your view and how
would you see that progressing going
forward
so that you're absolutely right and that
I mean that work is is underway as I as
I said at the very beginning every Force
has gone back and looked at all of those
all of those cases that are working
through their system and we're dealing
dealing with those cases and we're
dealing with them quickly we're getting
the chief councils in a place to do and
we are removing people from the
organizations that that fail to meet our
standards and really importantly as well
being transparent about that factor as
well now that does create some bad
stories because it's more police
officers being sacked but I think it's
really important for us to go through
and be very clear that we are doing that
there has been quite a bit of attention
placed on some of the hearings which are
chaired by independently legally
qualified chairs and there is some
evidence to suggest that that they take
a more lenient view than Chief
constables would take if they were
chairing a panel and I think the really
important point there is work that's on
going around that and I actually wrote
in respect to that to the Home Secretary
to to ask that that situation is looked
at and she has accepted that the the we
will look at this process around the
misconduct processes because I think
what's really important is of course any
process has to have due process and be
fair but it must very much must take
into consideration the impact on public
trust and confidence because that's the
fundamental point that we are we are
talking about here so I think that is
that is very much the case when it comes
to Chief councils and we need to look at
that system to ensure that nobody who
falls below the standards that we expect
remains in the service the final stage
of that process which can be problematic
is the police appeals tribunal so even
in cases where an officer is dismissed
because of the the the finding sometimes
a police appeals tribunal will seek to
reinstate and we've certainly been in
situations where forces have been have
had to resort to going to judicial
review processes to to challenge the
decision of a police appeals tribunal so
very clearly we need to get that system
working I think the system needs to be
looked at to ensure that all the
relevant parts are acting appropriately
it's done fairly it's done at the right
speed because one of the other
challenges that puts anybody off
reporting whether it's reporting a crime
or reporting internally is if you think
this is going to take another 18 months
for something to actually happen so it
needs to be done at speed but it
absolutely has to be against a a prism
which is about public trust and
confidence that when you ring the police
you can trust that the person that turns
up at your door is going to be behaving
appropriately
it'll be a painful process as the phrase
after news which is not flipping but
it's going to get worse before it gets
better and I think that's a really
important process that as a service we
go through so that we can cleanse
ourselves where there are those pockets
of either toxic culture or behavior that
is just not acceptable
emerged out on that the the college
provides specialized training for
officers who lead Professional Standards
and anti-corruption units we deliver
about 60 a year we also deliver
specialized training for anti-corruption
Professional Standards investigators and
as we've heard in earlier questions to
Rick Muir their house over the last 10
years been a buildup of a deficiency of
specialist officers in the right jobs
particularly investigations so we're
moving with specialized training to
rectify that the second thing is that we
do have authorized professional practice
on anti-corruption work and we gather
and disseminate good practice of what
works to keep our our Workforce honest
um in in respect of your question
thank you last question Chet
um many professions have a scrutiny if
you like and a mandate renewed with
politicians it's a Ballot Box how do you
feel about police officers having a
license to practice with it being
reviewed after five years
you want to go first and because it's
civil sort of Rick
um your as we heard earlier made a
recommendation of a license to practice
and in principle I want the best
possible training accreditation and
standards for police officers but we
have to move in a way which is practical
and unachievable for the service the
College of policing for many most of the
highest risk most specialized roles
delivers accredited training and annual
reaccreditation I'll give you an example
in an area which perhaps public not
fully aware of if you
use a place Firearms so you're an
authorized pharmacist officer you have
to have a certain amount of training per
year licensed by a training school a
forearms range by the College of
policing and any anyone in the command
structure bronze which is tactical
silver or gold which is strategic needs
to be licensed and accredited annually
by college the same is true by the way
of
um senior investigating officers public
order commanders and 21 000 public order
officers that respond to protest across
England and Wales so actually I'd love
to give you an exact percentage but a
very substantial number of police
officers and some police staff are are
accredited and licensed and one of the
areas that we're looking at now with
home office Partners is whether
um following the tragic shooting the
crime in Plymouth whether France license
officers should be annually accredited
and assessed by the College of policing
so in principle
um I do agree that that is a healthy
direction for any profession to take but
we may spend some more time talking
about the the degree apprenticeship the
new entry route
um we are undergoing
um some significant revolutionary
changes within policing at a time of
massive uplift and what what I would
always want to do as the College of
policing is achieved as much as possible
to the benefit of our public as quickly
as possible without breaking the system
or losing the people in it so I think my
opinion to move to that right now would
be a step too far
I mean there is no um set
um view of the apcc on this so if I'm
speaking in a personal capacity
um I think there is some Merit to this
um given like I said at the beginning
the the scale of responsibility and uh
powers that police officers have
um I I during this on a five yearly
basis I think as it was recommended it's
a bit of a concern to me because within
a year of someone joining policing
um foreign
that gets flagged up but one thing I've
got to just mention is that
um already the uh vetting departments
across all of policing is massively
massively overwhelmed with the vetting
of the very much welcomed um uh intake
of new offices
and that as far as I'm aware is
presenting some challenges with the
re-veting
of um current officer officers uh and
and so Chiefs are having to prioritize
uh their resources do you want to
prioritize the the vetting of uh new uh
intake or the re-veting of offices but
one of the assurance that I've been able
to
um get from from my Force for example is
wherever any serving officer has been
flagged up in any kind of complaint pip
by PSD which is Professional Standards
Department the revert the re-veting
process is escalated
so anyone that comes on the radar
will get that vetting priority but again
it's about people coming on radar until
after until when it is too late and that
that is a bit of a concern but like I
said policing is always carrying
carrying risks all the time and my
concern with this uh proposal even
though I'm generally in favor of it is
the extra demand that's going to place
on a very very overburdened veteran
vetting departments is that the case for
all
um police forces in terms of the ongoing
vetting of serving police officers is
that not being routinely undertaken
because of the pressure with the new
uptake that the new uplift there's I
don't think and it's not just simply the
new uplift but there is undoubtedly
always has been and there is a pressure
on the vetting units to do what they
need to do and I think I guess my you
know my answer to your question and I'm
I'm I'm very keen to look at anything
that we can do to improve where we are
but I'm also very practical and I want
something that's going to make a
difference I think in this Arena the
vetting processes and the work that's
being done to really look at those needs
to be done very clearly so we need to
make sure that when someone comes in
we're absolutely and the horror stories
that the chair refer to are not
happening we then need to be using
people's annual appraisal process to
identify changes and deal with that we
are trialing in a number of places
continuous
vetting where if someone pops up on
certain systems that automatically is is
raising a flag which I think is is
useful and of course one of the
challenges we have I guess with lots of
organizations currently the vetting
process is largely manual and we need to
get to a place where we've got a much
more automated process particularly
where a lot of what we're going to be
catching is to to look at is is sitting
in other systems so we need to do that
element whenever people go into a
specialist role or go into a sensitive
role there will be a re-veting process
at the higher levels of vetting at
certain year numbers of years you get
automatically re-vetted so there are all
of those going on and as Andy says in
terms of specific you know through the
years I've been accredited to lead
Firearms to do public order to be a
hostage negotiator whatever and all of
those things exist for and from the more
you know high risk issues but I don't
think just coming up with something
that's generic particularly when as
we've already said already and many
times the range of things that we're
expecting police officers to do it's
actually a generic license might not add
a huge amount of value but about
standards behaviors and that absolutely
needs to be locked in around vetting and
Professional Standards okay I'm going to
move to Simon fell
um
a couple of quick questions for me
um so firstly on trade-offs and
prioritization we've touched on some of
this already
um
first as you talked a lot about
um and very eloquently about
um the amount of time your officers are
spent
standing around
eating for for things to happen they're
outside of their their control
um what do you think
um officers should be doing more of or
police should be doing more of and less
of in terms of their prioritization
that is a very difficult question
uh because policing I've since found out
is one of those roles where it's very
difficult to say no when a call comes in
and I can tell you what I know one or
two offices one or two forces are doing
that I'm aware of uh which is when a
mental health job comes in they just say
no
uh and I am anecdotally informed that
the demand for those kind of calls have
fallen by about 60 70 percent
what I am trying to do in bedfordshire
somewhat controversially but it has got
people talking is to start sending bills
two local authorities two the mental
health teams
um every quarter and I'm going to start
that from next year because it is simply
becoming unsustainable it is sustainable
there is no need for police officers to
be sat in a e with the dementia a man a
gentleman who suffer from dementia he's
not under arrest hasn't come into any
crime uh and that is just not I don't
see how it can sustain that nor is it
acceptable for an ambulance call out to
be canceled just because a police
officer has ever seen
I mean that cannot continue
um so that is an area where I I think we
need to have much more cross
departmental working at the governmental
level to start trying to address this uh
but locally what I see some pccs and
police chase trying to do is to take a
more robust action especially around a
mental health jobs also around missing
children uh that the cases of children
who go missing from care settings uh and
they're not back home by their curfew
time of 10 pm for example and all that
just happens is a call for a police
welfare check comes in and the police
can't say no
uh so
in in my view those are some of the
areas uh where we need to start seeing
less police uh involvement direct police
involvement anyway and can I say so I'll
bring you in in just one second can I
can I just ask on that so
um
a lot of the issues that I see in my
constituency are due to sort of
centralized budget settings so they're
set in silos from from Westminster or
Whitehall or wherever it is
um and they don't address what is truly
a local need so you end up with the
police doing this backfilling function
because they are the the force of Last
Resort for one for a phrase
do you think local budget settings are
you sitting down with you know your your
equivalence in in your your local NHS
bodies and and other resource
departments to to understand what the
local need is and
divvying up how best to allocate budgets
would be a better way of doing things or
do you think it is just uh or do you
think it'd be better to have a clearer
direction from
um from Whitehall around where
responsibilities lie
um so you've got that Clarity of
judgment rather than local pooling
dilemma that many forces faces there are
police and crime commissioner in
consultation with the public
set the Strategic policing priorities so
they know what the Committees need and
then the budget allocation that they
have uh is agreed with the chief
constable and how that is going to be
used within the force however the
demands um there are non-policing
related will it into that resource
availability right and you can't say no
um so I think there's already some
element of flexibility in how resources
are allocated it's just that the the
mental health team they will have their
budget and that is their Core Business
and they'll stick to it policing same
thing
um education same thing but there's this
crossover between each and one of the
things that we are trying to do is so
for example in bedfordshire we and some
many other police force already have
this they have what they call Street
triage nurses where you have mental
health paramedic and police that travel
around together to a job where there
might be a police need there might be a
paramedic involvement there might be a
mental health requirement instead some
police and crime commissions they've
funded the mental health nurses in the
force control room I'm certainly doing
that on a full-time basis effectively so
there's this crossover between in
funding from the from the Mental Health
Trust
as well as police that is happening but
I'm still what I can still say to you
that the level of demand from those what
I would describe as non-policing police
demands
it is growing it is growing and somehow
we need to find a way of reducing that
so that the police can actually focus
more of their time on doing what they're
supposed to be doing
thank you very much
um so in terms of what what the police
should be doing College policing runs
are what works the database of crime
reduction over 200 measures
um and it includes such things as hot
spot Patrol 15-minute Patrol in crime
hot spots that means proven to reduce
crime so working in intelligence-led way
to do that attending burglaries I'm just
giving you some examples here
um spending more time doing high quality
investigations on for example rape and
serious sexual offenses crimes that
matter most of the public
investing in neighborhood policing teams
which are equipped to do multi-agency
problem solving to stop crime and
prevent crime in the first place and the
most recent addition to our smarter
practice website and by the way we're in
festus's force today looking at the
brilliant work they're doing on offended
management but the most recent addition
is is four things that police forces can
do to prevent homicide homicide and
prevention framework now all of that
evidence is fantastic the police need
time to do it without reducing someone a
non-place time they haven't got demand
but here is another thing that the
police need to do and historically have
not done efficiently in my time in
policing and if you have the chair of
the police Federation here he would tell
you the same they've not invested in
adequate continuous professional
development for all of our staff and
officers and some of our very
specialized people some are highly
skilled people like Martin have been
trained in accredited throughout their
whole career in public order Mark
command forearms command and other
things what about the response officers
what about the neighborhood Bliss teams
now actually this is difficult for
people like Festus he wants and I want
them out on the front line I want them
serving the public we have to invest in
the right training skills and knowledge
so they access this database and then
we've got to give them the right
leadership so they've got the time to
deliver it and fulfill their vocation
for the public
thank you so I mean I work with people
the others have said I I guess you know
what's our fundamental contract with the
public is when there is an emergency
when they are in distress we will we
will turn up and I think fundamentally
we we have to do that
however I think the challenge is that
and and the question you asked about the
local versus versus National I think is
really key because when we talk about
all of this non-police
demand if you like on non-crime demand
we're actually talking about a public
sector response to some form of some
person who is in vulnerable in distress
in whatever it happens to be and I don't
ever have a problem with us turning up
if the report comes in there is a person
who is behaving strangely is either
harming themselves harming other people
scaring people then of course we go the
challenge is we then stay because we are
largely the service that will go because
we will always go to that and I remember
sitting on the management board over the
river in the Mets when we agonized about
how do we reduce the non-police demand
and you would come up with lists of
things and then at the very end in a
business sense you would say that's not
our job we can't afford to go there we
would end up saying yeah but are we
really going to leave someone lying on
the ground at the side of the road the
challenge I think is whether it's at a
Westminster level or as you as you
alluded at a local level how are those
other services then coming in so that
that person isn't the same person on the
side of the road four days later and you
know you were in your Constitution your
police will talk to you about the repeat
individuals the children's home for
example the the idea that Festus you
know repeats going back and back and
back because in that Children's Home the
policy is and I understand why the staff
would do this if Joe blogs hasn't come
back at 10 o'clock we've got to report
that to cover ourselves and then we get
involved and then you end up trailing
around when that's not a missing I would
argue child that's a child who doesn't
want to be where they're supposed to be
and you get into all sorts of other
issues around that but so for me it's
about what is the public sector response
to the issues the preventive aspect but
we will always turn up when there's an
emergency because that's what we do and
I think that's what we are Contracting
and then you add all the other points
that that others have made about you
know particular crimes most harmful
crime things that make people fear crime
and the people that actually you know
that make people unsafe
thank you can I just pick you up on
something you said there around
um the core purpose of policing because
we've talked a lot about burglary we've
talked a lot about fraud and
um with the policy now being attending
every burglary
um that sort of that sits in quite a
stark opposition to where we are with
fraud and and cyber crimes and online
crimes of all kinds where
the experience for most people is if
they find out how to report it it
disappears into a black hole nothing
happens
they're very unlikely to get some form
of victim response
uh you're certainly not going to get an
officer knocking on your door asking you
know what happened and how did this
occur
um and and I'm just
I'm interested in your views on on what
you think that does to public confidence
when when it is a it is a crime you know
a crime has been committed against an
individual but the response is simply
not there versus an analog crime of a
burglary where there is now a very
visible response
um and what should we be doing to try
and improve for those more complicated
crime types so so beyond moving into
prevention and trying to stop them
actually responding to people who are
victims to those sorts of crimes yeah so
so I think it I think it does have a
negative impact on on people's
perception it comes to some of the
things that we've already said about the
public view is there anything to do with
crime is it's the police and and for me
the the point is is we've got to view
how we deal how we play our role in
those crimes in a different way the
burglary is physically located in a in a
police area and it and you've got all of
that investigation that you can do
the fraud where it's multiple victims
everywhere it's offender not here Etc so
I but I still think that the process
that we have at the moment is not good
enough to to make people recognize that
you are taking this seriously you are
dealing with the crime I mean Rick made
the point earlier about you know get
your money back in one of the things
that I was you know in in a burglary the
first agency that is the most important
organization to you is the police
because if if while I'm sat here
someone's stealing money out of my bank
account the first organization that I'm
going to want to speak to is the bank
because the bank will probably you know
or might put the money back in so we've
got to accept that we're in a different
place in terms of the role that policing
needs to play it needs to make sure that
people can feel I am reporting a crime
to to the police and they are taking
this seriously I think we've got to be
really clear with people about the
expectation of what that looks like it
is not forensic officers turning up and
looking for fingerprints in your burgled
house it's a different thing it's then
how we do the the education the kind of
prevention which in many cases is
educational as well so bank account is
one example the one that
um exercises me a lot is my children
when they're on their laptops and on
their computers and the vulnerability
there so there's a lot about how we're
educating people to be secure and safe
in their own in all of our own virtual
worlds and then I think and this is
where I think it is really important
that
um the the government and and
politicians are involved is is how we're
exerting pressure on all of those
organizations that actually have the
real crime prevention opportunity it is
it is the banks it's the organizations
that are moving the transactions it's
the applications it's the programs it's
all of that that none of us can
physically touch in the way that we can
physically protect our house or our or
our car or whatever and so I think it's
how we collectively as a as all of us
put pressure in there to make sure that
everything is being done as much as it
can be and then going back to some of
the stuff that Rick said you're clearly
not going to deal with all of that on a
force by force local basis but we need
to be working at that Regional working
with the National Crime agency and
working internationally as we do to make
sure that everything that can be done in
what is a complex kind of legal
framework where you know the laws quite
frankly struggle to keep up with what
the opportunities are for a criminal in
fraud and cyber in a way that we've
never seen you know for the first 25
years of my service things moved but
they moved reasonably slowly and the
methods that criminals use
the last sort of five ten years
technology wise has transformed that out
of all recognition that the way we're
vulnerable today we weren't vulnerable
six months ago and and the criminals are
all looking so they've got that's got to
be big level International work and it's
about how we do the prevention how we
put pressure on all those people who can
help prevent and then at the at the end
definitely we need to understand so we
get the intelligence picture and we need
to make you as a victim feel that we we
understand we get it we take it
seriously and we're doing what we can do
to stop it happening again
I'm going to ask people to be brief
because we are getting quite short of
time
just very very quickly in that here
herein lies the conundrum that police
Chiefs and police and crime
Commissioners face in that uh what we
are seeing is that a growing number of
the crimes that
um our residents are facing are online
so having a plea a Bobby on the beat as
many of us would want is reassuring uh
uh is comforting and so on and so forth
but Bobby on the beat cannot deal with
um your child being groomed in their
bedroom as even as they walk past your
home so the public want to have the
police on the door you know on their
streets but the real threat and harm is
happening in your very own home so
that's that's a real challenge there
okay okay Simon was there anything else
she wants to ask no okay Gary thank you
chair um Festus in the written
submissions by all the other groups here
today the police foundation College
policing and the National Police Chiefs
Council they all mentioned about the 43
force uh framework of policing across
England and Wales
um and do you think there is some merits
in the idea of
um helping behind the scenes on those HR
legal elements and the consistency what
do you think is the police and crime
commissioner's joint view if there's if
there is a joint view of how we can
change that framework what I what I will
say about that is that I mean I I we all
will obviously believe very strongly in
the local
Democratic accountability of policing
and I feel very strongly that the more
removed it is from the the communities
the more difficult it is to be able to
keep tabs on it for one of a better word
however there are are areas where we
should be seeing more collaboration in
my view HR and vetim is one of them I I
cannot understand as one of my
colleagues was saying to me this morning
why we have 43
vetting units and all of whim all of
whom have disparate outcomes right so in
some forces a vetting could take six
weeks in some will take six months for
the same role I I don't understand why
we need to have that level of complexity
and Divergence in in vetting uh so HR
definitely
I think from an operational level though
I think would need to keep I mean I
might disagree I could disagree with the
police foundation on this
um but I think the 43 model is is
reasonable in my view but one thing we
do have though I think we've got some
very good Regional organized crime units
who are now in play the rokues and just
really relating back to the previous
question the NCAA the National Crime
agent is actually now embedded with some
of the Rockies
uh so I think the regional um
collaboration I think is is there now
and they're working really reasonably
well they probably could do better but
we're not seeing but that's very much on
the Tactical operational policing level
I don't see the same level of
collaboration around things like vetting
and HR and I think that's probably an
area where we need to do more at okay
thank you I think it was probably about
10 years ago 10 years ago to this month
for police and crime Commissioners come
in because I think they have a distant
memory of campaigning in the rain in the
dark and in November which I think had a
12 turnout for police and crime
commission it's gone better since then
yeah well I think we've come a long way
um in the last decade on police and
crime Commissioners because the previous
system I don't think worked it was
normally just cancel as it sat on the
regional board it was very opaque it was
very difficult to get through and I'm
glad you point to the point to back
because the reason you're here is
because of about transparency
accountability in policing in a large
part of what you're actually responsible
for and people will point to you at as a
failure or a sex success locally is
those Elements which are therefore being
proposed to be joined so I'm glad that
you have a sort of skepticism about it
and it'd be interesting to know what the
other views are because I think I have a
distinct and ingrained skepticism of
centralization of any Skype because it
becomes more distant from accountability
more distant from transparency and I
think it is very important and I hope
you all agree but the more local it is
the better it is for people on the
ground so very briefly what I would say
um I think the question should we have
43 forces or a different number is the
wrong question
um the the real question the real
question is as as alluded to I think
earlier by Rick is for all the things we
ask police to do the police to do what
things need to be done at a very at a
local level what things are better done
regionally nationally and increasingly
internationally as well so let's work
and think about that rather than some
wholesale restructuring that would would
take forever and cost a fortune and and
then then I think the other point is the
point that the Festus made and really
what mptc
Drive collaboration and by collaboration
I don't mean for say and four speed come
together and create 4C I mean for some
of those things that we all have to do
either do them in gr so festus's forces
in a Triforce collaboration and has been
for some time there are others but we
need to be sensible and not use our
independence and our legal Independence
as I have to do it my way and you do it
your way let's think about those things
where we are better to do them either
for efficiency or Effectiveness and
often both let's collaborate and get
everyone to play their part and then
just work out because some things are
absolutely local and other things quite
frankly are international and there's no
point trying to do them 43 times locally
so that's how I would say so just we
need to ask the right question and then
challenge all of our all of those in
leadership positions to deliver
the agree with Martin some some things
can only invest be delivered locally and
what I know is a locally known police
leader and services accountable through
a police and crime commissioner to the
community however when I was chair
comfortable in Hampshire near Isle of
Wight I was a Founder member of enabling
Services collaboration with the County
Council on fire and rescue which now
provides HR finance and other services
for over 120 000 employees at low cost
and high Effectiveness I I do I don't
believe that we've yet reached anything
like Optimum collaboration on I would
generally call enabling services and I
welcome Rick muirs um findings in his
excellent report
[Laughter]
if we've got to keep them do you think
there should be more Regional base I.E
like a Midlands one rather than
county-wide
I will I'll answer it
um so I think I think having
um local accountability genuine
governance and accountability for
policing we need to have that we have a
we have a system in this country where
we are we are operationally
um independent to do what we do but the
quite rightly the public needs to be
able to
um hold us to account I would agree I
think the you know the previous system
didn't seem to work terribly well and
we're now 10 years in and I think
provided the relationship between the
police crime commissioner and the police
chief Constable our appropriate good
relationships then I think that system
can work and each knows its uh Place
each knows its place but I think
um I think the question clearly is there
and in all the in the kind of leveling
up conversations about whether you take
that to a to a larger level I think the
key question around the level is around
maintaining that relationship and
maintaining that genuinely being able to
say you are representing the views of
the public in whatever the scale of that
area is but as you well know we already
have mayoral models in London in
Manchester in the in the um uh in uh
West Yorkshire I I I'm going to ask you
uh if other members want to to say
something just to be brief because
sorry we've opened up a whole issue here
look I've been really breaking man I
think it's right Festus has the last
word I've worked with three different
police and crime Commissioners in two
police forces and I have been able to
witness the immense value of local
accountability police services that
they've brought for example in my last
police force under the the previous
commissioner so much Stevens she
extracted a commitment from me on
appointment in 2016 that I would not
reduce the number of pcsos and beat
managers in labored policing about 753 a
commitment I was very happy to make
publicly and she helped communicate that
to other agencies and then took a
pivotal role as Festus does I believe in
negotiating with other services and
agencies in that area about how do we
reduce the police demand how do we make
this criminal justice system work better
for local victims of crime and residence
so I think the system is what you get
out of it and I found it to be very
productive in two forces okay first if
you could be briefing it's almost like
asking the Prime Minister if the
chancellor of this Checkers or help our
hindrance it depends on which way you
choose to look at it
um look I think the first iteration of
bccs certainly provided some challenges
to police him as a whole and I think
we're not we're now in the third
iteration of police and crime
commissioner and I think each time it's
improved and both sides both bccs and
Chiefs are better appreciating and
valuing what both bring to the table and
I think it's only going to get better
over time so um my my answer is I would
say we are more of a help now and
support to policing overall and to our
public than say 10 years ago and now
that's going to continue getting better
okay
I am really sorry we are running out of
time but there are a number of questions
that I would still like you to answer so
I'm just wondering if I just raise them
with you now you might be able to write
to me and one is about
um The Institute for government said
that the proportion of recorded crimes
being charged
is at its lowest ever level and I
wondered if you could address that why
that is that's one thing the other thing
that we've not had much time to discuss
um it relates to the College of policing
and the use of data and research
evidence
allowing and helping then police forces
to to make decisions about priorities
and and so I wondered whether we could
have some information about that and I
know the what works Center for Crime
reduction and the National Crime and
Justice laboratory we'd like to hear a
bit a bit more about that that would be
very helpful
um I just wanted to ask a question about
the Masons
you know today we've talked about
transparency and openness and some of
the massage well the misogyny within the
police force I just wondered is being a
member of the Mason still
um prevalent and a problem in the police
force so that's a question I'd like to
ask
well I'd just like to ask that what I'll
say is that I had not one or two members
of the public raised this with me during
my election campaign and when I came
into role one of the questions that I
asked Chief constant was is this true
and his View and his answer was
categorically not so okay well if that's
the answer that's just what I'm
interested I've never been a free
emotion nor have I been asked to join
that particular Club but but I've been
in the place as I said 35 years I have I
have seen Masonic influence I I think
it's Wayne to a point of not not being
the issue that maybe it once was I think
the very fact that you're aren't asking
the question though shows that there's a
perception there that still needs
addressing yeah yeah and I think
I think conspiracy and openness
you know in light of particularly that
report this morning one wants to
question and see what's going on within
the police so I don't know
I mean likewise so I'm you know 30
something
um never been approached never been a
member I I knew it was there early you
know in the sort of late 80s or 90s 90s
very much Wayne as far as I'm aware it
pops up periodically and there will be
um when when something particular
happens it will pop up but I do think
it's a valid question at the point where
as you say sort of transparency about
the way that we will behave and of
course when you're talking about Mason's
what influences are being exerted in the
way that issues are being dealt with
particularly internally within the
organization okay well that's very
helpful you've answered that
um I also just wanted to ask you we've
talked a lot about the balancing and how
do you get this right and I wondered if
you might have examples of police forces
around the world where where you think
they've actually got to grips with some
of the new challenges facing policing
and are providing that you know
community policing but also dealing with
things like fraud and the internet and
all of that so if you've got examples of
where you think we ought to look that
would be very helpful to the committee
um
oh and just one other question which is
about this is a kind of more fundamental
question obviously the police force is a
command and control operation and what
we've been talking about today a lot is
discretion officers using their
discretion creative thinking about how
you work with other public sector bodies
so I wondered if you could say something
about the the tension there between that
command and control and and actually
wanting the creativity to make things
work on the ground
so if you could write to us with any of
your thoughts on those questions I'd be
very appreciative and I am really sorry
we're running out of time we're always
against a hard stop because of prime
minister's questions time on a Wednesday
and you can imagine there's a great deal
of interest at the prime minister's
question so can I thank all three of you
I think this has been an excellent panel
it's really helped us to understand the
challenges that you're all facing and we
look forward to
um hearing more from you but also the
questions that you're raising with us
now we will take forward in the panels
we have in the future so thank you thank
you very much for your time yeah my tie
just offer one other thing that we might
write to you it got mentioned in the
earlier session around the criminal
justice system and I would really I
think it's really important because
there's some really important issues
about how the system is or isn't working
and police's role in that but also the
perception around trust and confidence
where there are failings in the system
so I'd be very happy to just put some
thoughts in and you know that I think
might assist your review you that would
be great I mean we did a recent report
around rape investigations and
prosecutions and you'll know in there we
made very clear recommendations about
the criminal justice system and the the
issues that need to be addressed so yes
please do write to us okay thank you
again thank you
thank you